This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2019, two hunters were scouting for elk and Wyoming when they came across a peculiar feature in the landscape. The hunters had first noticed it while pouring over maps of the area. Now they were driving out to see it for themselves, a kind of break in the terrain near the state's southeast corner. So it's open country, it's open ranch country, sagebrush country. And then there's this big mountains sticking up right there in the middle of it that just it's the only mountain. Brad Cape is a fencing contractor from central Missouri.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2019年，两名猎人在怀俄明州寻找麋鹿时，偶然发现了一处奇特的地貌。他们最初是在仔细研究该地区的地图时注意到的。现在，他们正开车前往实地一探究竟，那是该州东南角附近地形上的一处缺口。那里是开阔的乡村，是开阔的牧场乡村，是长满艾草的乡村。而在那片乡村的中央，矗立着一座大山，它是那里唯一的山。布拉德·凯普是一位来自密苏里州中部的围栏承包商。
Brad has been hunting since he was old enough to walk. So when he and his hunting partner saw the lone mountain with its dark timber and the arid, empty land around it, he knew what it meant. It is a very unique place. And you can see on a map that it's a very unique place. But whenever you drive around it, it really comes to law. It is a rocky mountain that sits out by itself. You know, it might as well have a big bull's eye on it that says there's elk here. And it's true.
布拉德从会走路起就开始打猎了。所以，当他和狩猎伙伴看到那座孤零零的山，看到它深色的树木以及周围干旱、空旷的土地时，他明白这意味着什么。这是一个非常独特的地方。你在地图上就能看出它是一个非常独特的地方。但当你开车绕着它走时，它才真正变得生动起来。这是一座孤零零地矗立在那里的岩石山。你知道，它上面简直就像画了一个大大的靶心，写着“这里有麋鹿”。事实也确实如此。
The mountain basically screamed good hunting. That's Montana-based journalist Nick Mott. I'm a hunter too, so I get how Brad felt when he found this spot, pouring over land boundaries and topographic lines, trying to figure out where animals are and other hunters aren't, Finding that perfect area is often nearly as exciting as the hunt itself. And this time, all the pieces of the puzzle were fitting into place. The area had everything big game needed, forage, water, cover.
这座山简直在大声呼喊着“这里是绝佳的狩猎场”。说话的是蒙大拿州的记者尼克·莫特。我也是一名猎人，所以我理解布拉德发现这个地方时的感受，他仔细研究土地边界和地形线，试图弄清楚动物在哪里，而其他猎人又不在哪里。找到那片完美的区域，往往和狩猎本身一样令人兴奋。而这一次，拼图的所有碎片都拼凑在了一起。该地区拥有大型猎物所需的一切：草料、水源和掩体。
On the map, the peak was named Elk Mountain. Which, you know, was probably another big clue. And so we were driving around it. We're just seeing how close we could get to this mountain. And this sweet old gal pulls up there and rolls down her window and asks, if she can help us, you know. And we said, well, we're just looking for a way to that mountain. Is there a way to get to get up there?
在地图上，这座山峰被命名为“麋鹿山”。你知道，这可能又是另一个重要的线索。于是我们开车绕着它走。我们只是想看看能离这座山有多近。这时，一位和蔼的老太太把车停在那儿，摇下车窗问我们是否需要帮助。我们说，嗯，我们只是在找去那座山的路。有办法上去吗？
We'd like to, we're thinking about hunting it. And she's like, there's no way up there. A billionaire bought it, and he don't let nobody in. And we said, oh, okay, you know, well, is there any elk around here or deer around here? That's when this sweet old gal told them there were so many elk in the area. They'd actually become a nuisance, eating. the hay meant for cattle. And we just kind of looked at each other and said,
我们想去那儿，我们正在考虑在那儿打猎。她说，没路上去。一个亿万富翁把它买下来了，他不让任何人进去。我们说，哦，好吧，你知道，那这附近有什么麋鹿或鹿吗？就在那时，这位和蔼的老太太告诉他们，该地区的麋鹿多到甚至成了祸害，它们吃掉了原本留给牛的干草。我们俩面面相觑，说道：
yes, ma'am, thank you for your time, you know, and we were excited from that moment on that we were going to find a way in there. But finding a way in there wasn't going to be easy. Brad and his fellow hunters would end up trying to access Elk Mountain again and again and again, until eventually it wasn't even about hunting elk anymore. But something way bigger than that.
“是的，女士，谢谢您的时间。”你知道，从那一刻起，我们就很兴奋，我们一定要找到进去的路。但找到进去的路并不容易。布拉德和他的猎友们最终一次又一次地尝试进入麋鹿山，直到最后，这甚至不再仅仅是为了猎鹿，而是为了某种更宏大的目标。
And whether they succeeded or not would end up having lasting consequences for the future of land use everywhere in the U.S. Because the single largest obstacle preventing the hunters from making it onto Elk Mountain wasn't the elevation or the topography. It was how the mountain itself had been divided up into public and private land.
他们是否成功，最终将对美国各地土地使用的未来产生深远的影响。因为阻碍猎人们进入麋鹿山的最大障碍，并不是海拔或地形，而是这座山本身是如何被划分为公共土地和私人土地的。
When you look at that place on a map, it looks like a bunch of these little bitty squares. and when you start looking at it, you see that it is, it's a checkerboard. The checkerboard, as it's commonly known, is a phenomenon unique to the American West, a pattern of land ownership, which is found in huge areas from New Mexico all the way up to Washington. On a map, these particular areas look a lot like, well, a checkerboard, or perhaps checkered linoleum tiles. But instead of alternating black and white squares, checkerboarded land,
当你从地图上看那个地方时，它看起来像是一堆小方块。当你开始观察时，你会发现它确实是一个棋盘。棋盘式土地，正如人们通常所知，是美国西部独有的一种现象，这是一种土地所有权模式，从新墨西哥州一直到华盛顿州的大片地区都能见到。在地图上，这些特定的区域看起来很像棋盘，或者说是格子油毡地砖。但不同于黑白交替的方块，棋盘式土地，
alternates between single square mile parcels of public land and square mile parcels of private land. So every public square borders a private square, which borders a public square, which borders a private square, which borders a public square, which borders a public square, which borders a... Well, you get the idea. If you look out of an airplane window while flying over a checkerboarded area, it's not uncommon to see one square with a private housing development on it while the next sits relatively untouched. Or perhaps every other square features dense forest on public land while those private squares in between are logged. Again, just think of those alternating tiles. An image which Brad finds himself invoking all the time. Still, to this day, if I have someone asked me about this in the grocery store, I can't explain it unless I'm standing on a tile floor.
在每平方英里的公共土地和每平方英里的私人土地之间交替。所以每一个公共方块都与一个私人方块接壤，私人方块又与一个公共方块接壤，以此类推……好吧，你明白我的意思了。如果你在飞越棋盘式区域时从飞机窗户向外看，经常会看到一个方块上有私人住宅开发项目，而隔壁的方块却相对未受破坏。或者，也许每隔一个方块就是公共土地上的茂密森林，而中间的那些私人方块却被砍伐了。再说一次，想想那些交替的地砖。布拉德总是会联想到这个画面。直到今天，如果有人在杂货店问我这个问题，除非我站在瓷砖地板上，否则我无法解释清楚。
Because here in the Midwest and the rest of the country, they just don't get it. There's a catch, though, when it comes to hunting or doing anything really on the child. checkerboarded area. In the U.S., there's no legal way to pass through private property without the land owner's permission. That's trespassing. So public land in the checkerboard is often very difficult to access. After all, any public square in a checkerboard is surrounded on all sides by private property. It's only ever catty corner to other public squares. It doesn't matter that the public land belongs to us, the public. The reality is, it's only the owners of the adjacent private squares who have an easy way in.
因为在中西部和全国其他地区，他们根本不理解。不过，在棋盘式区域打猎或做任何事情都有一个陷阱。在美国，没有业主的许可，通过私人领地是不合法的。那是擅闯。所以棋盘式区域的公共土地通常很难进入。毕竟，棋盘中的任何公共方块四周都被私人财产包围。它只能在对角线上与其他公共方块相连。公共土地属于我们公众，这一点并不重要。现实情况是，只有相邻私人方块的业主才有便捷的进入方式。
These inaccessible public lands are what's called cornerlocked. So it's a big deal out west because you have the layout of public land out there, but you're just trying to keep the access to yourself. And when it came to hunting in the checkerboard on Elk Mountain, it was no different. The private half of the checkerboard belonged to a ranch, and the ranch wasn't allowing strangers to cross their land. But to Brad, that just made the public land all the more tantal. because it meant that it had the one thing that any good hunter was looking for.
这些无法进入的公共土地被称为“角落锁定”。所以这在西部是个大问题，因为那里有公共土地的布局，但你只是想把进入权留给自己。当谈到在麋鹿山的棋盘区域打猎时，情况也没什么不同。棋盘的私人那一半属于一个牧场，而牧场不允许陌生人穿过他们的土地。但对布拉德来说，这反而让公共土地更加诱人，因为这意味着它拥有任何优秀猎人都在寻找的东西。
No other hunters. So the next year in 2020, Brad and his friends, they decided to try something that in hunting circles is called corner crossing. Because something where nobody else would be, that's where I want to be. And in order to do that, we had to cross these corners. To understand corner crossing, think about a literal checkerboard. And a checkers game, a piece that starts on black needs to stay on black. So the pieces move diagonally, crossing caddy corner from the corner of one square to another.
没有其他猎人。所以第二年，也就是2020年，布拉德和他的朋友们决定尝试一种在狩猎圈子里被称为“跨越角落”的方法。因为在没有其他人的地方，那才是我想要去的地方。为了做到这一点，我们必须跨越这些角落。要理解“跨越角落”，可以想象一个真正的棋盘。在跳棋游戏中，从黑色开始的棋子需要保持在黑色上。所以棋子是斜着移动的，从一个方块的角落跨越到另一个方块的对角。
Moving through checkerboarded land works in the same way. To avoid the ranch's property, all Brad and his friends had to do was move around like a checker's piece. They'd start on public land and then make sure to stay on public land by only crossing into new squares diagonally at the corners where all those public squares touch. Tell me about, you know, you, I mean, so the way it works in this area, like, you, You set up camp, and your camp is in the first square that is publicly accessible, and then you cross from there? Like, how did that work? Yeah, that's exactly what it was. That's Phil Yeomens.
在棋盘式土地中穿行也是同样的道理。为了避开牧场的财产，布拉德和他的朋友们所要做的就是像跳棋一样移动。他们从公共土地出发，然后确保只在所有公共方块接触的角落斜向跨入新的方块，从而始终保持在公共土地上。告诉我，你知道，你是说，在这个区域它是怎么运作的？比如，你们扎营，营地在第一个可以进入的公共方块里，然后从那里跨过去？那是怎么运作的？是的，就是那样。那是菲尔·约曼斯。
Phil is also from Missouri, and he's been hunting with Brad for about a decade. Phil explained that this time, they all hiked from a public road towards the checkerboard's nearest approachable corner. When they got there, in the middle of this empty field, there was a little government survey marker about the size of a Coke can. There were also two no trespassing signs, along with a couple of posts called T-posts with a chain strung between them. Which was ironic, considering it was obstructing the one spot where they could legally cross. So we just grabbed whole the top of that T-post and swung our feet around, you know, kind of doing a little ballerina around the T-post so that we didn't touch the private property. Yeah, we weren't nonchalant about it. We were very specific, you know, as in we planted our foot exactly.
菲尔也来自密苏里州，他和布拉德一起打猎大约十年了。菲尔解释说，这一次，他们都从一条公共道路徒步走向棋盘最近的、可接近的角落。当他们到达那里时，在这片空旷田野的中央，有一个大约可乐罐大小的政府测量标记。还有两个“禁止擅入”的标志，以及几根被称为T型柱的柱子，中间拉着一条链子。考虑到它阻碍了他们唯一可以合法跨越的地方，这真是讽刺。所以我们只是抓住那个T型柱的顶部，把脚甩过去，你知道，就像绕着T型柱跳了一段小芭蕾，这样我们就不会碰到私人财产。是的，我们对此并不漫不经心。我们非常谨慎，你知道，我们精准地落脚。
From that point on, they made sure to stay entirely on public land their whole time inside the checkerboard. They corner crossed from one public square to another as they hunted for elk on elk mountain. And from the start, the mountain proved true to its name. Man, that first morning, the bulls were bugling. We could hear them from the county road. and once we got up to the place we decided we were going to camp we saw a big old herd coming walking down the side hill and we just stood there and watched them and was like this is going to be good but we were up the mountain up the mountain up the mountain and we ended up so far up that mountain we drank water out of an elk track seeping out of the hill that day and this elk's bugling just as far away as you can hear, you know.
从那时起，他们确保在棋盘内的整个时间都完全待在公共土地上。他们在麋鹿山猎鹿时，从一个公共方块跨越到另一个公共方块。从一开始，这座山就名副其实。天哪，第一个早晨，公鹿在鸣叫。我们在县道上就能听到它们的声音。当我们到达决定扎营的地方时，我们看到一大群鹿走下山坡，我们只是站在那里看着它们，心想这会很棒。但我们一直在爬山，爬啊爬，最后爬得太高了，那天我们甚至喝了从山坡渗出的麋鹿足迹里的水，那只麋鹿的鸣叫声远到你所能听到的极限，你知道。
They would go on to harvest three big bull elk, and I can tell you, this is a big deal. Most elk hunts lead to nothing, mine included, and these guys got a haul. But things weren't all sunshine and roses and big bugling bulls, because just as they were field dressing a bull elk, a man appeared in the distance. And he makes the walk over to us, which took quite a while.
他们最终收获了三头大公麋鹿，我可以告诉你，这可是件大事。大多数麋鹿狩猎一无所获，包括我自己的，而这些人却满载而归。但事情并非全是阳光、玫瑰和鸣叫的大公鹿，因为就在他们处理一头公麋鹿时，远处出现了一个人。他朝我们走过来，花了不少时间。
We just kept work, you know, because they're half of mine. you know from us as the man walked over Brad's friend Zach thought something felt wrong and started recording on his phone so he just walks up to us and ask us what we're doing there you know and was a little snotty about it hey how we're doing bad how are you worn out yeah how'd you get in here it was the ranch's manager a man named Steve Grindy. The hunters told Grindy they got here by crossing from a public section of land to another public section, at a corner. So on that first corner with the signs on it, how did you get through that? Grabbed the deep boats to fall around it. It's got a chain on it so you can't go
我们只是继续工作，你知道，因为它们是我的一半。你知道，当那个人走过来时，布拉德的朋友扎克觉得有些不对劲，开始用手机录像。他走过来问我们在那儿干什么，你知道，态度还有点傲慢。嘿，我们做得怎么样，布拉德，你好吗？累坏了吧？是的，你们是怎么进来的？那是牧场的经理，一个叫史蒂夫·格林迪的人。猎人们告诉格林迪，他们是通过从一块公共土地跨越到另一块公共土地，在角落处进来的。所以在那第一个有标志的角落，你们是怎么穿过去的？抓住T型柱绕过去。它上面有链子，所以你不能从中间穿过。
between them. But it's also on private property. Anytime you touch that thing, it's criminal trespassing. That's why they're there. But the hunters had done their research. They pointed out that Wyoming Fish and Game, and even the state attorney general, had said that crossing at corners was legal. But Grindy countered. You can't corner jump in Carvin County.
但它也在私人财产上。任何时候你碰到那个东西，就是刑事擅闯。这就是它们在那里的原因。但猎人们做了调查。他们指出，怀俄明州鱼类和狩猎部门，甚至州总检察长，都曾表示在角落处跨越是合法的。但格林迪反驳道。在卡文县你不能跨越角落。
Period. I believe everything we read says we can. Well, I'm just going to have to go to the court and have them decide. Right. That's fine. Okay. As uncomfortable as the encounter was, it wasn't out of the ordinary.
没门。我相信我们读到的一切都说我们可以。好吧，我只能去法院让法官来决定。好的。没问题。尽管这次相遇很不愉快，但这并不罕见。
Spats over corner crossings happen between hunters and landowners all the time. Ultimately, it's all part of a much larger war over public and private land and the checkerboard that began over a century and a half earlier. The U.S. government has been in the business of dividing up government-owned land into squares since 1785. The system was the brainchild. of Thomas Jefferson, who dreamed of selling all those squares to a nation of small yeoman farmers. But the actual checkerboarding of the land began at the tail end of the Civil War when policymakers in Washington wanted American settlers to move west.
猎人和土地所有者之间关于跨越角落的争执时有发生。归根结底，这是一场关于公共和私人土地以及棋盘式土地的更大战争的一部分，这场战争始于一个半世纪前。美国政府自1785年以来一直致力于将政府拥有的土地划分为方块。该系统是托马斯·杰斐逊的创意，他梦想着将所有这些方块卖给一个由小自耕农组成的国家。但土地的实际棋盘化始于内战末期，当时华盛顿的决策者希望美国定居者向西迁移。
Because as anyone who's ever played Oregon Trail knows, moving out west was hard. Beyond the 100th meridian, most settlers struggled to access the necessary supplies to get their homesteads up and running or their goods to market. So, in the mid-1800s, the U.S. government turned to the railroads to move those supplies for them. Only, it turned out that the railroads also needed help. The railroad's not going to build by themselves. The reason they're not going to build by themselves is there's nobody out there and no traffic. You don't build the railroad into the middle of nowhere.
因为正如任何玩过《俄勒冈小径》的人所知，向西迁移很艰难。在第100条经线之外，大多数定居者难以获得必要的物资来建立家园或将货物运往市场。因此，在19世纪中期，美国政府求助于铁路公司来为他们运输这些物资。只是，事实证明铁路公司也需要帮助。铁路不会自己修建。它们不会自己修建的原因是那里没有人，也没有交通。你不会把铁路修到荒郊野外。
This isn't field of dreams, and you just hope they'll come if you build it. Richard White is Professor Emeritus of History at Stanford, and the author of the book Railroaded, the Transcontinentals and the Making of Myles. modern America. So what you're going to do is you're going to have to get aid in building the railroad. The federal government says we are going to prime the pump. White says the United States was cash poor, but land rich. So the government gave the railroad company's long corridors of land, up to 80 miles wide on which to build new rail lines. The railroads could then sell or lease that land to whomever they could lure west, but the government only granted the
这不是《梦幻之地》，你不能指望只要修了，他们就会来。理查德·怀特是斯坦福大学历史学名誉教授，也是《铁路化：横贯大陆铁路与现代美国的缔造》一书的作者。所以你要做的是，你必须在修建铁路方面获得援助。联邦政府说我们将启动这个项目。怀特说，美国当时缺钱，但土地资源丰富。因此，政府给了铁路公司长达80英里宽的土地走廊，用于修建新的铁路线。铁路公司随后可以将这些土地出售或出租给他们能吸引到西部的任何人，但政府只授予了
railroads every other square mile of land. Hence, the checkerboard. With the checkerboard, the government could keep all the undeveloped sections in between and wait for them to go up in value before turning around and selling them to more developers. The new railways would also transport the soldiers needed to push Native Americans off the land the U.S. had promised them and onto reservations. So this becomes a means of conquest. And once it's there, once Indian lands can be sold to build the railroads, then the railroads can become the agency for conquering any remaining Indian resistance. So this is how the whole system works. And in this way, it does become an agent of colonization. Under this system, a lot of land changed hands.
铁路公司每隔一平方英里的土地。因此，就有了棋盘。通过棋盘，政府可以保留中间所有未开发的区域，等待它们升值，然后再转手卖给更多的开发商。新的铁路还将运送士兵，这些士兵被用来将美洲原住民从美国承诺给他们的土地上赶走，并送往保留地。所以这成为了一种征服手段。一旦铁路建成，一旦印第安土地可以被出售来修建铁路，那么铁路就可以成为征服任何剩余印第安抵抗力量的代理机构。这就是整个系统的运作方式。通过这种方式，它确实成为了殖民的代理人。在这个系统下，大量土地易手。
And all, over 130 million acres went to the railroads. And to put that in perspective, if all the federal grants to railroads were combined into one state, if you called it Railroadiana, It would be the third largest state in the United States, behind Texas and Alaska. One company alone, the Northern Pacific Railroad, received an amount of land roughly the size of New England. And almost all of it was given away an alternating one-square-mile sections. So the checkerboard on paper, this is a system is ideal. What can possibly go wrong? It seems to be foolproof.
总共超过1.3亿英亩的土地给了铁路公司。为了说明这一点，如果将所有联邦给予铁路的赠地合并成一个州，如果你称之为“铁路亚”，它将是美国第三大州，仅次于德克萨斯州和阿拉斯加州。仅北太平洋铁路公司一家，就获得了大约相当于新英格兰地区大小的土地。而且几乎所有土地都是以交替的一平方英里部分赠送的。所以棋盘在纸面上是一个理想的系统。会有什么问题呢？它似乎是万无一失的。
But like most systems that seem to be foolproof, they're usually designed by fools. and that's what's going to happen here. When the railroads sold their land, it went to timber companies, it went to miners, it went to developers, but especially ranchers, who saw a sort of two-for-one bargain on all that checkerboarded property. All you had to do was buy the private squares and then fence off all the adjacent public squares, and they would effectively be yours for the keeping, too. By the 1880s, big cattle barons had fenced in millions of acres of land they didn't own.
但像大多数看起来万无一失的系统一样，它们通常是由傻瓜设计的。这就是这里将要发生的事情。当铁路公司出售他们的土地时，它流向了木材公司、矿工、开发商，尤其是牧场主，他们看到了所有这些棋盘式财产中的一种“买一送一”的便宜货。你所要做的就是买下私人方块，然后围起所有相邻的公共方块，它们实际上也就成了你的囊中之物。到19世纪80年代，大牧场主已经围起了数百万英亩他们并不拥有的土地。
But homesteaders and smaller-scale ranchers and farmers, weren't happy about all that fence. The fences block settlers, because settlers have to be able to drive their wagons, get to railroad depots, and they're blocked by fences. The tension between settlers and ranchers quickly grew ugly. There were standoffs, shootouts, murders. Later on, dime novels, radio programs,
但定居者和规模较小的牧场主及农民对所有的围栏并不满意。围栏阻挡了定居者，因为定居者必须能够驾驶马车，到达铁路仓库，而他们被围栏挡住了。定居者和牧场主之间的紧张关系很快变得恶化。发生了对峙、枪战、谋杀。后来，廉价小说、广播节目，
and television shows like Gunsmoke would dramatize this era, known as the Range Wars. Does cattlemen built his country, Matt? A few more years now they'll have us fendons. stop. Times changed, Ben. In 1885 in an effort to curtail the power of the big ranchers, Congress
以及像《荒野大镖客》这样的电视节目将这一时期戏剧化，被称为“牧场战争”。是牧场主建立了这个国家，马特？再过几年，他们就会把我们围起来。停止。时代变了，本。1885年，为了削弱大牧场主的权力，国会
finally stepped in and passed the Unlawful Inclosures Act, which guaranteed public access to public land. You can still build fences around your own land. You can control access if there hasn't been in a right-of-way established across your own land, but you cannot enclose
最终介入并颁布了《非法圈地法》，该法案保证了公众进入公共土地的权利。你仍然可以在自己的土地周围建造围栏。如果你的土地上没有建立通行权，你可以控制进入，但你不能圈占
public land, and you cannot enclose land that you do not own. Today, the unlawful enclosal Enclosures Act is still on the books. But the act never did much to break up the ranches and other big properties of the Western U.S. And those large landowners never stopped looking for ways to secure their property, including in the checkerboard. That part never seems to change. So Jefferson's dream of this whole thing ending up as being small farms, that is just simply not the case. The West ends up as a place of very, very large land holdings.
公共土地，也不能圈占你不拥有的土地。今天，《非法圈地法》仍然有效。但该法案从未在打破美国西部的牧场和其他大型地产方面发挥太大作用。而那些大土地所有者从未停止寻找确保其财产安全的方法，包括在棋盘区域。那部分似乎永远不会改变。所以杰斐逊关于这一切最终成为小农场的梦想，根本不是那么回事。西部最终成为了一个拥有非常、非常大地产的地方。
And it still very much was when Brad and the the hunters stepped from corner to corner of public land in 2020. After that first hunting trip, they could easily have left and just never come back. Why risk another awkward run-in? But in the end, the hunting was just too good. Plus, they'd spoken with law enforcement who told them they were good to go. After all, the Unlawful Enclosures Act was still in force. So the following year, they went back to hunt Elk Mountain.
当布拉德和猎人们在2020年从公共土地的一个角落跨越到另一个角落时，情况依然如此。在那次狩猎旅行之后，他们本可以轻易离开，再也不回来。为什么要冒再次发生尴尬冲突的风险？但最终，狩猎体验实在太好了。此外，他们曾与执法部门交谈过，对方告诉他们可以继续。毕竟，《非法圈地法》仍然有效。所以第二年，他们又回去猎麋鹿山了。
But this time, just to be on the safe side, they made one small adjustment. to their corner crossing strategy. The only thing that we had that the ranch complained about was that we touched their T-post. You know, so we just had to get past that T-post without touching it, and then there was nothing that they could say. So that's where the whole ladder idea came in. If they shouldn't touch the T-posts, then why not find a way to climb right over them? What did you build? Like, how did you build the ladder?
但这一次，为了保险起见，他们对跨越角落的策略做了一个小小的调整。我们唯一被牧场抱怨的就是我们碰到了他们的T型柱。你知道，所以我们只需要在不碰到T型柱的情况下越过它，然后他们就无话可说了。这就是整个梯子想法的由来。如果他们不应该碰T型柱，那为什么不找个办法直接爬过去呢？你们造了什么？比如，你们是怎么造梯子的？
This, you know, this wouldn't be my solution necessarily. I wouldn't think about building a ladder. Like, how do you, what goes into it? Well, I guess maybe if you were a pole vaulter, you would take a pole vault with you. I was a fence guy, you know, so I had access to a lot of pipe and a welder, so just went back there in the shop and welded some pipe together. Brad fashioned together a ladder that unfolded to a specific height, length, and width. The dimensions allowed it to go right over the tee posts,
这，你知道，这不一定是我的解决方案。我不会想到造梯子。比如，你怎么做，需要什么？好吧，我想也许如果你是撑杆跳运动员，你会带一根撑杆。我是做围栏的，你知道，所以我有很多管子和焊机，所以就回到车间把一些管子焊在一起。布拉德拼凑了一个梯子，可以展开到特定的高度、长度和宽度。这些尺寸允许它直接越过T型柱，
and across the corner, all without ever touching the ranch's property. And when the hunters crossed using Brad's ladder, just like the time before, other than those T-posts, there were no fences, no gates, no other infrastructure. The hunters designed, built, set up, and climbed a specialized ladder to cross through empty airspace in an empty field, just so they could say that this time they were following the very letter of the law. Carvin County Sheriff's Office. Hi, this is Stephen Grindy with Elk Mountain Ranch again, Colin.
并跨过角落，所有这些都没有碰到牧场的财产。当猎人们使用布拉德的梯子跨越时，就像上次一样，除了那些T型柱，没有围栏，没有大门，没有其他基础设施。猎人们设计、建造、设置并爬上了一个专门的梯子，穿过空旷田野里的空旷领空，只是为了证明这一次他们是在严格遵守法律条文。卡文县警长办公室。嗨，我是麋鹿山牧场的史蒂夫·格林迪，再次致电。
We had an issue with some trust passers out here off rattlesnake paths and a canvas tent. Not too long after the hunters got there, that same ranch manager from earlier, Steve Grindy, recognized their truck from the previous year. He called local law enforcement agencies repeatedly. Eventually, a sheriff's deputy and fish and game officer both showed up. How's going? Steve. Here's the body cam footage. Have you seen them cornered fast?
我们在响尾蛇小径和帆布帐篷附近遇到了擅闯者。猎人们到达后不久，之前那位牧场经理史蒂夫·格林迪就认出了他们去年的卡车。他反复致电当地执法机构。最终，一名副警长和一名鱼类与狩猎官员都出现了。你好，史蒂夫。这是随身摄像机的录像。你看到他们跨越角落了吗？
Yeah, we just watched them. And it's posted. I have signs right there too. Jump this corner right here. What they have is a ladder that they put down and go over. Grendi's efforts to keep the hunters out of the public land went beyond phone calls to police. At one point during the trip,
是的，我们刚看到。而且贴了告示。我那里也有标志。跳过这个角落。他们有一个梯子，他们放下来然后过去。格林迪阻止猎人进入公共土地的努力不仅仅是给警察打电话。在旅行期间的某个时候，
Grendi poked his head in the hunter's tent and got escorted away by an officer. Another time, he tracked the hunters down in his truck, cursed them out, and tailed them while they were hiking on a road that passes through public land. And as the law enforcement officers giggled about the ladder in that body cam footage, a frustrated grindy let this slip. Do they realize how much money my boss has? The ranch was owned by a pharmaceutical executive from North Carolina named Fred Eschelman. I reached out to Eschelman and his lawyers for an interview. Neither got back to me.
格林迪把头伸进猎人的帐篷，被一名警官带走了。另一次，他开着卡车追踪猎人，咒骂他们，并在他们徒步经过公共土地的一条道路时跟踪他们。当执法人员在随身摄像机录像中对梯子窃笑时，沮丧的格林迪脱口而出。他们知道我老板有多少钱吗？该牧场由一位名叫弗雷德·埃舍尔曼的北卡罗来纳州制药高管拥有。我联系了埃舍尔曼和他的律师进行采访。两人都没有回复我。
But we know Eschelman told the ranch manager to keep talking to the authorities until they could get the hunters prosecuted. And eventually, Eschelman's strategy worked. The county attorney charged Brad, Phil, and their hunting partners, John Sluinsky and Zachary Smith, with criminal trespass, and sent a sheriff's deputy to their campsite. Again, here's the body cam footage. All right, so just so it's not a surprise, you guys are all going to get cited for criminal trespass. I'm a surprise After what we've been But we still don't understand why
但我们知道埃舍尔曼告诉牧场经理继续与当局交谈，直到他们能起诉猎人。最终，埃舍尔曼的策略奏效了。县检察官以刑事擅闯罪起诉了布拉德、菲尔以及他们的狩猎伙伴约翰·斯卢因斯基和扎卡里·史密斯，并派了一名副警长到他们的营地。再次，这是随身摄像机的录像。好吧，为了不让你们感到意外，你们所有人都会因刑事擅闯被传唤。我很惊讶，在我们经历了……之后。但我们仍然不明白为什么。
With this citation The hunters were facing Up to six months in jail Plus a big fine So in Wyoming If you Go past the private boundary Or a marked area
有了这张传票，猎人们面临着最高六个月的监禁，外加一大笔罚款。所以在怀俄明州，如果你越过私人边界或标记区域，
It is considered trespass So Elk Mountain Ranch is marked Is no trespassing So that's what they're going to use Is you guys went beyond the boundaries of the Elk Mountain Ranch. But if I never touch Elk Mountain Range, you know,
它被视为擅闯。所以麋鹿山牧场被标记为“禁止擅入”。所以这就是他们要利用的，你们越过了麋鹿山牧场的边界。但如果我从未触碰麋鹿山牧场，你知道，
if I never touch the ranch, how did I trespass? So it's, this has been a point of contention in Wyoming for a long time. Right. So especially, so it's 20 miles north and south of the railroad is the checkerboard. Right. And it's been this way for a long time.
如果我从未触碰牧场，我怎么擅闯了？所以，这在怀俄明州长期以来一直是一个争论点。对。所以特别是，铁路南北20英里就是棋盘。对。而且这种情况已经持续很长时间了。
So hopefully you guys can come back and fight it. When we come back, Brad and the other hunters do just that. Stay with us. And we're back with the story of America's public lands and whose checkerboard it really is. When the Wyoming Sheriff's Office charged the hunters with criminal trespassing on Fred Eschelman's land, things might very easily have just ended there. After all, at that point, it really was just a matter of corner crossing in this one area on this one ranch. There were plenty of other places in the country they could go hunt elk. You know, we went back and forth contemplating whether we were going to just plead guilty, pay the $750 or what it might be.
所以希望你们能回来反击。当我们回来时，布拉德和其他猎人正是这样做的。请留步。我们回到了关于美国公共土地以及它到底是谁的棋盘的故事。当怀俄明州警长办公室以刑事擅闯罪起诉猎人进入弗雷德·埃舍尔曼的土地时，事情本可以很容易地就此结束。毕竟，在那一点上，这确实只是在这个牧场的这个区域跨越角落的问题。全国还有很多其他地方可以去猎麋鹿。你知道，我们来回权衡是否要认罪，支付750美元或类似的东西。
None of us were too concerned about the six-month-in-jail-type thing. But although the stakes for Brad and Phil and the other hunters personally were low, the principal involved, like part of something bigger, starting with their belief that corner crossing to access public land, which, again, is something hunters and other people do all the time, is legal. It's such a simple concept. I got a six-year-old grandson. I could point this to him very simply, and he would easily end up on the right side of this. This is just smoking mirrors to try and steal the public's land. So they decided to lawyer up. To when, they would need someone with experience representing both hunters and ranchers, someone who knew the laws, both spoken
我们中没有人太担心六个月监禁的事情。但尽管布拉德、菲尔和其他猎人个人面临的风险很小，但所涉及的原则，就像更大事情的一部分，始于他们相信跨越角落以进入公共土地（这再次说明，这是猎人和其他人一直在做的事情）是合法的。这是一个如此简单的概念。我有一个六岁的孙子。我可以非常简单地向他指出这一点，他很容易就会站在正确的一边。这只是为了窃取公众土地而制造的烟雾弹。所以他们决定请律师。为了获胜，他们需要一个既有代表猎人又有代表牧场主经验的人，一个了解山区西部法律（无论是明文还是不成文）的人，一个知道模拟刮擦痕迹和摩擦痕迹之间区别的人。归根结底，他们需要一个像他们一样的人。他们找到了瑞安。我的名字是瑞安·萨马拉德。我是卡斯珀的一名律师。你是否了解，艾米丽，你是一名猎人、垂钓者，你是否了解本案中关于公共土地的问题？不，我从来没有打过猎。我想我只钓过一次鱼。瑞安最初来自纽约，而不是怀俄明州。但他的妻子来自该地区，当他们想要孩子时，
and unspoken of the Mountain West, someone who knew the difference between a mock scrape and a rub line. They needed, when it came down to it, a guy like them. They got Ryan. My name is Ryan Samarad. I am an attorney in Casper. Were you in tune with, Emily, were you a hunter, an angler, were you in tune with sort of public land issues in this case? No, I have never hunted. I think I have caught a fish once. Ryan is originally from New York, not Wyoming. But his wife is from the area, and when they wanted to have kids,
他们决定搬到离她家人更近的地方。这就是带我们回到怀俄明州的原因，这也是我在这里的唯一原因。起初，瑞安不知道该如何处理这个案子。他们把它描述为“跨越角落”案。我以为，我错了，但我以为那一定意味着一些非常奇怪和乡村的事情，比如推牛案之类的，
they decided to move closer to her family. And that's what brought us back to Wyoming, and that is the only reason that I am here. At first, Ryan had no idea what to make of the case. They described it as a corner hopping case. I assumed, and I was wrong, but I assume that must have meant something really weird and rural, like a cow tipping case or something,
或者你，你知道，没关邻居的门。我真的不知道。但瑞安和一些当地朋友谈过。他们告诉他，这在这里是一件大事，而且已经持续很长时间了。他们发给他一份研究报告，他了解到，尽管最初的棋盘式区域大部分已被买下并合并成这些单一的地产，但今天美国西部仍有超过800万英亩的公共土地
or you, you know, left your neighbor's gate open. I don't really know. But Ryan talked to some local friends. They told him, this is a big deal here, and it has been for a long time. They sent him a study, and he learned that, although a lot of the original checkerboarded area had been bought up and consolidated into these single land holdings, today more than 8 million acres of public land across the western U.S.
保持着“角落锁定”状态。那是一片仅比瑞士略小的公共土地，除了像埃舍尔曼这样的土地所有者外，对任何人来说都完全无法进入。就在那时，我意识到这可能是一个比这一个案子更大的问题。所以瑞安同意在刑事审判中代表其中一名猎人，但当他收到通知说牧场主弗雷德·埃舍尔曼也决定起诉猎人时，他最终在民事法庭上代表了他们所有人。埃舍尔曼辩称，他购买牧场时理解跨越角落
remain corner-locked. That's an area of public land only slightly smaller than Switzerland, completely inaccessible to anyone except for landowners like Eschelman. That's when it kind of dawned on me that this was maybe a bigger issue than just this one case. So Ryan agreed to represent one of the hunters in the criminal trial, but he ended up representing all of them in civil court when he got noticed that Fred Eschelman, the owner of the ranch, had decided to sue the hunter. too. Eschelman argued that he had bought the ranch with an understanding that corner crossing
是非法的。现在突然允许它，意味着猎人和休闲者会经常擅闯他的私人财产。在他看来，这种混乱将有效地使土地贬值。他起诉的具体金额随时间而变化，但他将总成本定为高达900万美元。当你告诉菲尔、布拉德和其他人时，你听到的反应是什么？是的。好吧，我会告诉你，当你告诉任何人“嘿，你知道，你有这种风险”，尤其是这些人时，那是一个非常艰难的时刻。
was illegal. Suddenly allowing it now would mean an influx of hunters and recreationists regularly trespassing on his private property. The chaos, as he saw it, would effectively devalue the land. The exact dollar amount he was suing for changed over time, but he put the total cost as high as $9 million. What is the reaction you're hearing from Phil and Brad and the others when they, when they hear that. Yeah. Well, I will tell you, that was a pretty tough moment when you tell anybody, hey, you know, you have this exposure, and especially these guys.
我的意思是，他们不是制药高管，他们不是亿万富翁。900万美元，你知道，那是金融末日。尽管对于两个面临金融末日的人来说，布拉德和菲尔对此表现得相当冷静。是的，所以我告诉过你，我是卡车修理工。就像，伙计，我不知道。我想我最大的担心是，你知道，我想确保我的妻子，我们仍然有一个家，但我想如果他想要我的2013年雪佛兰Silverado，我想他可以拿走。如果说有什么不同的话，埃舍尔曼起诉他们的金额太高了，以至于没有达到预期的效果。菲尔认为900万是可笑的，布拉德也这么认为。
I mean, these are not pharmaceutical executives, they are not billionaires. $9 million, you know, that's financial apocalypse. Although for two people facing financial apocalypse, Brad and Phil seemed pretty stoic about it. Yeah, so I told you, I'm a truck mechanic. Like, buddy, I don't know. I guess my biggest concern was, you know, I want to make sure my wife, we still have a home, but I guess if he wants my 2013 Silverado, I guess he can take it. If anything, Eschelman had sued them for too much money for it to have the desired effect. Phil thought 9 million was laughable, Brad, too.
那个金额太离谱了。如果他只是说几十万，那会吓到我。但在数百万的范围内，你知道，这根本不是一个现实的数字。但埃舍尔曼并没有被吓倒。他只是不断施加更大的压力。我以前从未见过这种情况。
That dollar amount was so outrageous. If he had just said a couple hundred thousand, that would have scared me. But in the millions, you know, it just wasn't a realistic number. But Echelman wasn't deterred. He just kept applying more pressure. I've never seen this happen before.
这让我感到震惊。在我们等待刑事审判开始、陪审团选择开始时，陪审员们正在排队进入，法院工作人员正在排队进入，我的当事人都坐在那里，一名副警长走到他们每个人面前，在陪审团面前又给他们发了一张传票。所以又是一张罚单，又是一项刑事指控，这次是针对2020年的那次首次跨越，
It kind of shocks me. is while we were waiting for that criminal trial to begin, for the jury selection to begin, jurors are filing in, court staff are filing in, my guys are all sitting there, and a sheriff's deputy walks up to each of them and issues them one more citation in front of the jury. So another ticket, another criminal charge, this time for that first crossing back in 2020,
整整一年之前他们认为自己正在受审的那次经历。所以，是的，那是我们第一次了解到这一点。我看着瑞安。我说，好吧，你想要我怎么处理这个？他说，扔进垃圾桶。审判就是这样开始的。很好。法院恢复开庭。法院审理的案件是怀俄明州诉布拉德利·凯普、约翰·斯洛因斯基、菲利普·约曼和扎卡里·史密斯。在刑事审判中，州政府的律师辩称，即使猎人在2020年像芭蕾舞演员一样越过T型柱或在2021年爬过它们时没有踏上私人土地，他们也穿过了
a whole year before the ordeal they thought they were being tried for. So, yeah, that's when we first learned. about that. And I kind of hand it to, I kind of looked at Ryan. I said, well, what do you want what do I do with this? He said, throw it in the trash. And that's how the trial began. Great. Courts back in session. The matter before the court is the state of Wyoming versus Bradley Cape, John Sloinski, Philip Yeoman, and Zachary Smith. In the criminal trial, the state's lawyers argued that even if the hunters didn't set foot on private land when they ballerined over the T-posts in 2020 or climbed over them in 2021, they passed through air
牧场拥有的领空。作为业主是有价值的。这很重要。边界也很重要。在怀俄明州，法律规定你不仅拥有地面，你不仅拥有土地，你还拥有领空。在你们来到这里之前，你们中有多少人知道这一点？瑞安的辩护由几个不同的点组成。
itself that's owned by the ranch. Being a property owner has value. It matters. So do boundaries. And in Wyoming, the law is you don't just own the ground, you don't own the earth, you own the airspace. How many of you knew that before you came here? Ryan's defense consisted of a few different points.
但基本上，它归结为猎人从未进行过物理擅闯的想法。此外，他们也有土地权利。只是在他们的情况下，这是进入公共土地的权利。政府不能在不补偿的情况下拿走你的土地，那是一种征用。但同样，私人土地所有者也不能拿走公共土地。那不是他们的。那是我们所有人的。随着审判的进行，其他事情也在发生。
But basically, it came down to this idea that the hunters never physically trespassed. Plus, they had error in land rights, too. Only in their case, it was the right of access to public land. Government can't take away your land without compensating that's a take. But just so, private landowners can't take the public land. It's not theirs. It's all of ours. And as the trial wore on, something else was happening.
各种各样的人开始注意到，包括多年来一直与棋盘式圈地作斗争的猎人和环保主义者。还有徒步旅行者、骑自行车的人和渔民，他们多亏了新的GPS地图应用程序，现在可以看到棋盘的全部范围和所有那些无法进入的公共土地。记者们也产生了兴趣。甚至在审判结束之前，《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》和《华尔街日报》都刊登了关于四名密苏里州猎人、他们的小梯子和跨越角落的专题报道。狩猎和公共土地倡导团体召集成员为辩护筹集资金。
All sorts of other people started to take notice, including hunters and environmentalists who have been struggling with checkerboard enclosures for years. But also, hikers, bicyclists and fishermen, who, thanks to new GPS mapping apps, could now see the full extent of the checkerboard and all that inaccessible public land. Journalists got interested too. Even before the trials had ended, the New York Times, the Washington Post, in the Wall Street Journal, all ran features about the four hunters from Missouri, their little ladder, and corner crossings. Hunting and public lands advocacy groups rallied members raising money for the defense.
对于那些关注的人来说，这个案子变得比怀俄明州的这一个小方块更重要。它是关于全国范围内公众进入公共土地的问题。它的意义，数百万英亩的土地，你知道，被锁定的角落土地，它只是，它是公共土地。这就是它。它属于公众。是的，它属于每个人。它不应该被垄断。
And for those paying attention, the case became about something larger than just this one little square in Wyoming. It was about public access to public land all over the country. The significance of it, the millions of acres, you know, the cornerlock land, It just, it's public land. That's what it is. It belongs to the public. Yeah, it belongs to everybody. And it shouldn't be monopolized.
我住在蒙大拿州，那里有很多公共土地，也有很多棋盘式乡村。即使在这里，距离布拉德和菲尔跨越的地方500多英里，他们的案子也引起了轰动。不久前，我在瑜伽课上遇到一个人，穿着一件“跨越角落不是犯罪”的T恤。所以你到了一个无法退出的地步。这是一件道德上的事情。这一切都是，对吧？
I live in Montana, where there's a lot of public land and also lots of checkerboarded country. Even here, more than 500 miles from where Brad and Phil crossed, their case made waves. I ran into a guy in a yoga class not too long ago wearing a corner crossing is not a crime t-shirt. So you get to a point where you can't back out. It's a moral thing. It's all of that, right?
这就是为什么它变得比我们更重要。虽然案件的社会地位提高了，但法律风险也随之上升。猎人在两次审判中都赢了，但民事案件最终提交到了美国第十巡回上诉法院。第十巡回法院位于丹佛，负责监督六个西部州。这不再是一个小型的、一次性的案件，甚至不仅仅是一个在怀俄明州确立先例的案件。巡回法院有权决定跨越角落在这六个州是否合法。结果将决定谁能有效进入大量的公共土地。而埃舍尔曼的一方，现在得到了其他一群土地所有者的支持，已经向第十巡回法院提起了上诉。
And that's why it became bigger than us. And while the social status of the case got bigger, the legal stakes climbed two. The hunters won at both trials, but the civil case ended up before the U.S. Tenth Circuit Court of Appeals. The Tenth Circuit is based in Denver and oversees six Western states. This wasn't a small one-off case any longer, or even a case just setting the precedent in Wyoming. The circuit court had the power to settle whether corner crossing was legal in all six of those states. The outcome would decide who got effective access to a huge amount of public land. And it was Eschelman's side, now backed up by a bunch of other landowners that had appealed to the 10th Circuit.
这就是为什么它变得比我们预想的还要大。随着案件的社会地位不断提升，法律风险也随之增加。猎人们在两次审判中都赢了，但民事案件最终被提交到了美国第十巡回上诉法院。第十巡回法院位于丹佛，管辖着六个西部州。这不再是一个小型的孤立案件，甚至不再仅仅是怀俄明州的一个先例案件。巡回法院有权决定“角落穿越”在所有这六个州是否合法。判决结果将决定谁能真正进入大片公共土地。而现在，埃舍尔曼一方在众多其他土地所有者的支持下，向第十巡回法院提起了上诉。
They were the ones who wanted to go big. Ryan told me what he thought that meant. They have this kind of imperial intent that it's our lands, the lands they bought, and all of these public lands too. That's really what this case is about. They're going to shut out the public from the public lands. So May 2024, you're in Denver. Have you made arguments in front of a circuit court before? No. They're very first time. It looks like everybody's ready to go. With that, let's call the first case, which is 23-8043 Ironbar Holdings versus take. You may proceed.
他们是那些想要大干一场的人。瑞安告诉我他认为这意味着什么。他们有一种帝国式的意图，认为这是我们的土地，即他们购买的土地，以及所有这些公共土地。这才是本案的真正核心。他们打算将公众拒之于公共土地之外。所以2024年5月，你在丹佛。你以前在巡回法院进行过辩论吗？没有。这是第一次。看起来大家都准备好了。那么，让我们传唤第一个案件，即23-8043 Ironbar Holdings诉Cape案。你可以开始了。
Good morning, Your Honors. You may it please get court. The morning of the Tenth Circuit hearing, an armada of well-respected attorneys showed up representing Eschelman. And since Eschelman's side brought the suit, they went first. Some of the arguments had more or less stayed the same from the criminal trial. But now things got more nuanced. Eschelman's team argued that private property is a building block of society. Property lines have sharp edges because of...
早上好，法官阁下。请允许我发言。第十巡回法院听证会那天早上，一群受人尊敬的律师代表埃舍尔曼出席了。由于是埃舍尔曼一方提起的诉讼，他们先发言。一些论点与刑事审判时基本保持一致。但现在情况变得更加微妙了。埃舍尔曼的团队辩称，私有财产是社会的基石。产权界线有明确的界限，因为……
the consequences of eroding them. So there's practical implications of this case that I want to address. The gist of their argument was what Eschelman had maintained all along, that whatever high ideals we might have about public lands, the on-the-ground reality was that legalizing corner crossing would be an invitation for chaos. In places without government survey markers, and there often aren't any, people would start to accidentally trespass all the time if corner crossing was legalized. But also, there was no need to permit corner crossing. The government already had better tools at its disposal to resolve the problems created by the checkerboard. All of this can be fixed by the government tomorrow. If the government wants to
破坏它们的后果。所以这个案件有我想解决的实际影响。他们论点的要点是埃舍尔曼一直坚持的观点，即无论我们对公共土地有什么崇高的理想，现实情况是，将“对角穿越”合法化将招致混乱。在没有政府测量标记的地方，而且往往根本没有，如果“对角穿越”合法化，人们会开始无意中一直非法侵入。但同时，也没有必要允许“对角穿越”。政府已经有更好的工具来解决棋盘式土地格局带来的问题。所有这些都可以由政府在明天解决。如果政府想要
create access, just as they have gone from 150 million acres of originally locked land, today, less than 9 million remains. They are making progress. And that's true. Although those last nine million acres have proven tricky to eradicate, there are various mechanisms for erasing the private squares in the checkerboard or just letting the public pass through. Eschelman's side argued there's no need to override all that policy for the sake of some elk hungry hunters. If anything, this is a question for the legislature and local agencies, not the courts. Meanwhile, Brad and Phil and the other hunters were streaming the proceedings from Missouri. They didn't attend the oral arguments in person. When you watch it,
创造通道，就像他们已经将最初锁定的1.5亿英亩土地减少到今天不到900万英亩一样。他们正在取得进展。这是事实。尽管最后这900万英亩土地已被证明难以消除，但有各种机制可以抹去棋盘中的私人方块，或者只是让公众通过。埃舍尔曼一方辩称，没有必要为了某些渴望麋鹿的猎人而推翻所有这些政策。如果有的话，这是一个立法机构和地方机构的问题，而不是法院的问题。与此同时，布拉德、菲尔和其他猎人正在密苏里州直播诉讼过程。他们没有亲自参加口头辩论。当你观看时，
did you guys like get together? Did you watch it separately? No, we watched it separate. We all work. May it please the court, Ryan's summary after the police. When it was Ryan's turn to speak, Brad and Phil could both tell as they listened in that Ryan's core arguments
你们聚在一起了吗？你们是分开看的吗？不，我们分开看的。我们都要工作。请法庭允许，瑞安在警察之后的总结。当轮到瑞安发言时，布拉德和菲尔在听的时候都能感觉到瑞安的核心论点
were also much the same as in that first trial. You can't exploit the interlocking land pattern to deny everybody else the benefits while you reap them all. But this one moment toward the end of the hearing stood out to them both. For me, it was when, and I don't remember the judge's name, he said, yeah, I don't believe our Congress intended when they wrote the laws, and this checkerboard pattern was first made. They didn't intend it to block the public.
也与第一次审判时基本相同。你不能利用这种交错的土地格局来剥夺其他所有人的利益，而你自己却独享它们。但在听证会快结束时，有一个时刻让他们两人印象深刻。对我来说，那是当——我不记得法官的名字了——他说，是的，我不相信我们的国会在制定法律和最初形成这种棋盘格局时有这种意图。他们无意阻止公众。
If you look back at when the railroads were going across, Congress said we want to give the railroads half the land and the public half the land. Did Congress really intent, the judge asked. for the public to have no real right to the land from their half of the deal. If somebody had just posed the question that way to Congress, I have no doubt how they would have answered that question. This past March, nearly a year after the oral arguments in Denver, the U.S. 10th Circuit Court of Appeals issued its opinion on the case of Iron Bar Holdings v. Cape. That day, Ryan, was in court in Wyoming.
如果你回顾铁路穿过的时候，国会说我们想把一半土地给铁路，一半给公众。法官问道，国会真的打算让公众在他们的那份交易中对土地没有任何真正的权利吗？如果有人当时就这样向国会提出这个问题，我毫不怀疑他们会如何回答。今年3月，在丹佛口头辩论近一年后，美国第十巡回上诉法院就Iron Bar Holdings诉Cape案发表了意见。那天，瑞安在怀俄明州的法庭上。
So I try to rush back to the office and I print off the opinion and I sit down to read it. and just what I'm about to read? And as I read it, it was just, it was perfect. In many ways, the opinion was everything Ryan and Brad and the other hunters had argued for since the very beginning. The court laid out the history of the West, the railroads, the checkerboard grants, the enclosures, the range wars. It explained how the land is supposed to work. The opinion said, these public lands in the West, they're for everyone. And that's who they were always for.
所以我试着赶回办公室，打印出判决书，坐下来阅读。我正要读什么？当我读到它时，它简直太完美了。在许多方面，这份判决书正是瑞安、布拉德和其他猎人从一开始就一直争取的。法院阐述了西部的历史、铁路、棋盘式赠地、圈地运动和牧场战争。它解释了土地应该如何运作。判决书说，西部的这些公共土地是属于每个人的。而且它们一直都是属于他们的。
So we win corner crossing is not a trespass in all six states. The Tenth Circuit's decision won't bring total closure. After Echelman's team appealed again, the U.S. Supreme Court refused to take up the case, which means that, for now at least, the status of corner crossing and public land access in the other 44 states remains murky. The last time I met up with Brad and Phil, they are passing through where I live on their way to their big annual Western hunting. trip, this time in Montana. Here, we're in the Ninth Circuit, along with other Western states with lots of checkerboarded land like Idaho, Oregon, and Washington.
所以我们赢了，“对角穿越”在所有六个州都不是非法侵入。第十巡回法院的裁决不会带来彻底的终结。在埃舍尔曼的团队再次上诉后，美国最高法院拒绝受理此案，这意味着至少目前，在其他44个州，“对角穿越”和公共土地准入的状态仍然模糊不清。我最后一次见到布拉德和菲尔时，他们正路过我住的地方，前往他们一年一度的西部狩猎之旅，这次是在蒙大拿州。在这里，我们处于第九巡回法院管辖区，与其他拥有大量棋盘式土地的西部州（如爱达荷州、俄勒冈州和华盛顿州）一样。
Montana's Fish and Game Agency has said, corner crossing remains unlawful here, so don't do it. But other authorities in the state disagree, and the issue remains as unclear as ever. It's unlikely Brad and Phil will be involved in whatever comes next. The whole saga has already taken up four years of their lives, and that, they said, was a But talking with them, I could tell they're a little bit bummed the Supreme Court didn't take up the case. The way they see it, there's still more locked up land that needs to be freed. You could never dream in a million years that you would end up here over something so simple as making one step. Yeah, you know, we didn't set out to do this.
蒙大拿州的鱼类和野生动物管理局表示，“对角穿越”在这里仍然是非法的，所以不要这样做。但该州的其他当局不同意，这个问题仍然像以前一样不明确。布拉德和菲尔不太可能参与接下来的任何事情。整个传奇已经占据了他们四年的生活，他们说，这已经够了。但与他们交谈时，我能感觉到他们对最高法院没有受理此案感到有点沮丧。在他们看来，还有更多的封闭土地需要被解放。你永远不会在一百万年里梦想你会因为迈出一步这样简单的事情而走到这一步。是的，你知道，我们并不是故意要这样做。
You know, we just wanted to go hunt elk. Would you guys ever corner across again? Absolutely. Absolutely. We put in now every year since, I believe, for Oak Mountain. Yes. We're going back. We don't know when, but we're going back. Why do you want to go back so bad? I think because we can. Ninety-nine percent Invisible was reported this week. week by Nick Mott and edited by Joe Rosenberg.
你知道，我们只是想去猎麋鹿。你们还会再进行“对角穿越”吗？绝对会。绝对会。我相信从那以后我们每年都为橡树山提交申请。是的。我们要回去。我们不知道什么时候，但我们会回去。为什么你们这么想回去？我想是因为我们可以。本周的《99%隐形》由尼克·莫特报道，乔·罗森伯格编辑。
Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real, fact-checking by Graham Hesia. Special thanks this week to Savannah Tate Wright, Aula Cousie's, and Melody Star Edwards. Kathy Tew is our executive producer. Kirk Colstead is the digital director Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lajemadon, Kelly, Kelly, Kelly, Kelly, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
由马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·里尔配乐，格雷厄姆·赫西亚核实事实。本周特别感谢萨凡纳·泰特·赖特、奥拉·库西斯和梅洛迪·斯塔·爱德华兹。凯西·特是我们的执行制片人。柯克·科尔斯特德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德里昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、拉杰马顿、凯利、凯利、凯利、凯利、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马斯。99%隐形标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Sirius XM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。
In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及99PI的每一集往期节目，网址是99PI.org。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。